[Music]
casey
yeah what is your favorite restaurant in
this area that you
are always dying to get me to go eat and
i'm always like nah you go eat their
boys
yeah i like samwo sam whoa
i don't know which location oh [ __ ]
that's the one here the street
that's the one right here that's it
alhambra no what happened
you don't like dead ducks in the front
of a store i love it and carcasses of
pigs i'm a weird person i just don't
like this
it makes my mouth do you even like food
no i don't
serious question no seriously yeah i
just need to survive
well now i have found joy in certain
foods but that's a long story
anyway the point is this is sam who's
the chain one right yeah the team
i'm one i'm really curious what this
news is right now i feel like i know
the daughter yeah oh yeah yeah well
okay so i had a party at her house the
one in samolino
is that one well so for those of you
that are not local
this is a la county based restaurant
chain and it's a popular hong kong style
restaurant
and like casey's barbecue
they have like hanging ducks in the
front it's just very
traditional delicious it's a delicious
half of freaking roast pig yup half a
roast
all that right and so it's delicious
the chef is uh smoking a cigarette
indoors
wearing sandals he's popping a squat
like this
no it's your peeples so
oh it just has great memories there yes
but it turns out
oh don't tell me no i was going to go
there right now
it's not real regardless what happens
we're going what are you thinking bart
you look shocked
i was thinking what's the anticipation
it might be a front for like
interior design crimes
their interior design at those
restaurants is a crime oh it's so funny
i don't know what they're doing out of
everything you could have said that
was so good their menus some of them is
like a [ __ ] back
of a printed paper and they'll write
some [ __ ] in marker
and be like today's special and then
they just put it on the wall like that
they do do that it's really yeah it's
like that well
it's not for crimes i've been up there
since the 97
night it's been up there since the 70s
or something except for that crime
it is for a crime oh [ __ ]
something happened and i'll tell you
right now okay so gary chung
the owner of this chain
face there was a daughter younger face a
total of
107 charges and he
pleaded guilty to filing a false
sales tax return and failure to pay
payroll taxes and filing a false income
tax return
among others so here's here's the here's
a breakdown no
um so he was i'm not surprised he was
accused
of restaurants to run a fraudulent tax
and workers comp insurance scheme from
january
2012 to march 2019.
and so they're saying that the members
of the tax recovery
in the underground economy task force
completed the investigation into
gary chung's schemes and so during that
period
they concluded that he failed to report
the following information number one
over 16 million dollars in sales to the
department of tax
and fee administration number two over
14 million dollars in tax of
taxable income to the franchise tax
board
number three over 2.1 million dollars in
wages to the employment
development department and number four
over 2.1 million dollars in wages to
insurance carriers
that's a lot of [ __ ] yeah so they're
saying that he
evaded payment of two million four
hundred and fourteen thousand seven
hundred and sixty nine dollars so
precise cents
oh down to the cents in sales tax income
tax and payroll tax
and and forty 549 thousand six hundred
and six
dollars in workers comp insurance all of
that he didn't report and they're only
gonna find him 2.5 million dollars
no so he evaded payment of that and the
well
oh got you invaded that value and then
now
this is what he has to pay in
restitution two million nine hundred and
sixty four thousand
three hundred and seventy five dollars
and ninety three cents
and he pleaded guilty and so he owes 16
million something no he didn't report
that
so he would have owed 2.5 million in
half a million to workers
2 million income tax yes yeah
and so they're saying that he will serve
at least three years in prison
or nine years and four months
if he fails to pay that amount that i
just the last amount
[ __ ] yeah i mean that's how they got al
capone
on tax evasion they get a lot of uh
the high uh crime lords
they can't pin them on like violent
crimes or murders
yeah so isn't there proof evidence
that's where rico came
like the recall laws so then they can
get the whole organization
but also like al capone um
what one he was so distant
from all the things that you know the
hitmen get in trouble but like no one
squeals
i actually do it yeah he didn't actually
do it and then
they could never prove that he called
the hit no one squealed on him
so they only was able to get him on tax
evasion that was the only thing they
were able to get him on
so if drug dealers and murderer like
these big kingpins just pay their taxes
they don't have to worry about [ __ ]
if they're really good all across the
board well that's hard to say because
you can't say like if all these
drug kingpins pay their taxes because
like even like paying taxes on the money
that they're making
it's like claim where the money's coming
yeah it's like dirty money illegal money
so it has to be laundered so
even that tax evasion that's that's
tax evasion on like their business
fronts right on fronts yeah yeah
so this is uh he's doing tax avoiding
he's not you know he's not reporting
taxes
things like that so man that's crazy
2.5 million dollars and if you don't pay
and he's facing time
that's [ __ ] up to be fair i would
assume
that like 90 of like you know asian
business people especially during that
generation they're all guilty
do the same thing relative to their
yearly income
yep so the difference is he just was
successful he's a mobile yeah yeah
where some people are doing the same
percentage-wise the kind of invasion or
he got caught as well most of those
places don't even take card
yeah it's cash only and then like every
so yeah
every every x amount of years they'll
change the name of their business so
that they just kind of like the previous
business kind of ups and
leaves and just yeah i wonder when we're
gonna hear like
no leave that out
can you imagine that cook
with the cigarette that was chopping up
all the duck heads
that full is actually an irs like
undercover agent
i know cause they have a little task
force and [ __ ] yeah because that they
they must have gone from like imagine
though like they gotta like [ __ ] put
microphones in like the ducks
but they don't know so they put like oh
nobody's gonna eat this part it's the
feet
if they do it like today's special tuck
feet from nine years ago
but dude you know it's crazy this was
only in a seven year period and this
restaurant
opened over 40 years ago so they've been
invading
yeah a lot more to it than that they're
not probably i mean but
they can probably only get them up until
not necessarily maybe they were doing
everything the totally legit way for
like 33 years
and then one day it was like [ __ ] it
yeah you don't know that's true
you don't know yeah and there's multiple
too so he could have been evading
across a bunch of the restaurants i
think he personally owns
them all like it's not a franchise
so i don't know i mean but they did
mention the franchise board
they didn't pay the fees or whatever
i don't know that's crazy man it's it's
it's crazy because like
okay well we know that it exists it's in
our backyard yeah it's a restaurant that
we're
so familiar with but you know that they
a lot of
asian cash businesses do things like
this right like it's
it's you always hear about it but you
never know exactly how it's done
maybe they're not as successful as he
was so he was on their radar or they
weren't on
the other restaurants around the world
maybe he's doing an example out of him
too it's like hey we'll take down the
biggest guy in this department in this
area and like all you other
[ __ ] are better cleaner i'm not
safe
yeah yeah it's dangerous man because
like there's okay so there's like legal
loopholes that you can do
but when you just blatantly do a legal
[ __ ] like this
you're playing with fire because you
could build an empire but it can all
come crashing because you didn't do it
legit
and man that's crazy isn't it crazy how
like
like amazon will pay like one dollar tax
or something
like because they have enough money to
like get it offshore do all these crazy
things
they're also smart enough to do it too
yeah and then and then these guys are
trying to
do it in their own way but they're still
a small
business compared to like apple google
and all these guys
and because they have the money in power
they can do
other things like that are crazier like
in in the billions of dollars
because this is this is pretty big but
his
place is very humble like it looks like
a whole wall like you go in there i
honestly did not know that this was a
chain until this story well this one is
humble
there's one in uh cerritos and it looks
like a
like a like a buffet asian spot yeah
like a chinese
seafood restaurant so some of them are
actually like like big it's just that
one is like a small home
like the first location yeah but when
you see the spot though it
it doesn't feel like like you're in
mcdonald's or something corporate yeah
like so then when you hear these you
could just tell from the front it's
mind-blowing it's really humble
the humble place that one yeah that one
yeah that's probably the smallest
location out of all the locations really
is the only one i've ever seen so
that's why i thought it was just like a
mom and pop kind of like because the
other one that i grew up on in cerritos
they're kind of smart where it's a
little bit more of a simulated city
so the the one the the front of the
store
that faces the street it feels like a
sizzler like you're like oh okay these
guys they know what packaging and how to
present it to like the american
uh palette they don't have the the
printed paper on the walls or the
hanging ducks
so if you go it's actually a two and one
so if you go in the back where the
parking lot is
that's where the to-go section is so if
you pick up to go that's where all the
hanging ducks are
but no one smart no one that's like
american when you go to a restaurant you
don't try to find the back entrance yeah
what's going on well yeah they have one
in temple city that's like
more it's like a cafe two one one two
yeah and on the
take outside it's like the hanging ducks
these uh you think these businesses are
gonna close down because of this or uh
they better not this better not affect
the actual
restaurants the pandemic already as it
is a lot of restaurants are already just
struggling like crazy
that's why everyone's saying like just
buy local like
don't go to these chains during these
times right now they look like a local
spot though yeah
i know it's a hometown favorite or i
didn't mean specifically samuel i meant
like
like dominoes or something yeah we
should stop by samuel we should
i feel like i should support him now
yeah he needs our help more than ever
yeah it's it's weird because like when i
think about these restaurants
like all right i'm not thinking like oh
man they're tax evading how [ __ ] up
i feel like now they need more money to
pay their employees
because they have to now pay the [ __ ]
right and i'm always thinking about
the server and the cook and the people
that actually run the place i'm not
thinking about the people that own it
yeah well to be fair too though like i
would assume that
uh not reporting income tax for your
workers
and or workers comp means that he was
probably paying people under the table
yeah which for that type of position
that's not like it's not like you're
working there's a career with health
benefits or anything like that you don't
mind the cash and less tax liability for
yourself anyway
it's usually a win-win but it's illegal
yeah
because it's a win-win for the boss and
the employee but
lose for the government it's lose for
the community because
we rely on those tax dollar dollars to
you know from businesses to be allocated
to other things so i think
that's where it's kind of [ __ ] up you
know what and then you think about it
though
because that's how it should be right
where sales tax goes back into the
community like fix the roads
give school or schools money and all
this [ __ ] but then once it reaches that
level there's so much corruption there
that it doesn't even get distributed to
community either so then these business
owners are like
well i might as well [ __ ] keep my
money then like why am i giving it
to the city no it's not even working for
me yeah like is the irs gonna come in
you know what i mean be like all right
now you gotta pay like three million
dollars
you know and then once he pays three
million dollars it's like all right
here's at least one million that goes
back to your city
that's not gonna happen no yeah three
million is gone exactly so
it's it's a little bit what's the word
i'm looking for it's not very uh
inspirational
right for for the proper business
etiquettes mechanics
uh for everybody to follow that
especially for you know asian people
that came in during this time frame
they needed all the help they can get
you know yeah for sure he's successful
now and
at the same time not because of this but
you know at that time
and for any immigrant who came over it's
like
you're in survival mode you're not in
follow the rules mode you're gonna do
whatever you need to do mode you know
what i mean
you